we have heard the recent statements that
russia will scale down military
operations around kiev and in northern
ukraine
but russia has repeatedly lied about its
intentions
so we can only judge russia on its
actions
not on its words
according to our intelligence
russian units are not withdrawing but
repositioning
russia is trying to regroup
resupply
and reinforce its offensive in the
donbass region
at the same time russia maintains
pressure on kiev and other cities
so we can expect
additional offensive actions
bringing even more suffering
russia must end this senseless war
withdraw all its troops and engage in
talks in good
faith
also i welcome all efforts to try to
find a political solution to this brutal
senseless war
including the recent talks in in turkey
and i will also thank turkey for hosting
those talks at the same time
it is obvious that
we have seen little
willingness
from the russian side to find a
political solution what we see
is a continued
military invasion of ukraine we see
continued shelling of cities
and we see that russia are
re-positioning some of the troops
moving some of them around
most likely to
reinforce their efforts in the donbass
region so
we need to judge russia on
their actions not on their words and it
remains to be seen where there is any
real willingness from the russian side
to find a political solution let me add
one more thing and that is that of
course there is a close link between
what is going on on the battlefield and
what is going on around the negotiating
table and nato allies provide support to
ukraine uh to also strengthen their
position at the negotiating table
i'll be very careful speculating too too
much about the likelihood but what i can
say is that any use of chemical weapons
will be a
blatant violation of international law
uh it will
change the nature of the whole conflict
and uh and the nato allies
uh have also uh
uh made it very clear that of course
that will have severe consequences
um uh nato allies
uh have also provided some support to
ukraine
to help protect against chemical and
biological warfare protective equipment
equipment to detect and identify a
chemical attack
but on the likelihood i'm not speculate
i will only say that any use of chemical
weapons will be absolutely unacceptable